in the world of Hollywood animation
Disney's pantheon of princess movies are
the gold standard of light-hearted
family fun with singing animals big eyed
heroines guaranteed happily ever afters
and the nice comfortable G rating across
the board there's nothing even remotely
dark or disturbing about these whimsical
films until you take a peek at the
horrifying tales that based on he has a
look at the creepy stories behind the
Disney Princess movies frozen frozen
broke major ground for Disney as a
feel-good feminist friendly entry into
its canon of classic princess fare and
to accomplish that all he had to change
about the source material was well
everything frozen is based on Hans
Christian Andersen's The Snow Queen a
lengthy meditation on the nature of evil
in the original story The Snow Queen
isn't a misunderstood teenager
struggling to bear the weight of her
epic ice making powers and the legacy of
some seriously lousy parenting instead
she's a cold creepy inhuman villainous
who kidnaps a little boy named Kai
smooches him to give him amnesia and
then forces him to do math puzzles all
day and night in her ice palace talk
about sadistic by the time Kai's sister
finds him several years later he's a
frostbite ridden shadow of his former
self
good luck turning that into a cuddly
action figure Cinderella like most of
Disney's classic animated films this
dreamy old-school princess story was a
complete nightmare in its original
incarnation for one thing Cinderella's
father is alive and well in the fairy
tale by the Brothers Grimm he's not just
there to see how badly she's being
treated he's complicit in it for another
Cinderella in her original incarnation
isn't so much a hapless servant girl as
a powerful sorceress who inexplicably
tolerates being treated like slime by
her family even though she can conjure
magic with her tears a dream is a wish
your
[Music]
and Cinderella's stepsisters they don't
just embarrass themselves when they try
to pretend they're the owners of
Cinderella's missing slipper
they literally dismember their feet to
make the shoe fit one of the sisters
shops off her big toe and the other
removes a piece of her heel in both
cases the Prince Tony notices something
is wrong when a bunch of talking birds
point out to him that his bride shoe is
filling up with blood and that's not all
at the very end of the story the sisters
show up at Cinderella's wedding and walk
her down the aisle in a shameless
last-minute attempt to curry her favor
at which point the talking Birds who
have had just about enough of this
social climbing nonsense fly down and
peck their eyes out The Little Mermaid
we all know the story of sweet Ariel who
fell in love with a human and got a
well-deserved happy ending with a
princely husband but while Disney's
Little Mermaid lived happily ever after
as part of your world the Hans Christian
Andersen's story that the movie was
based on is a much much darker affair
full of dismemberment murder existential
crises and exactly zero reggae jam
musical numbers composed by a crotchety
talking crab
[Music]
in the original Little Mermaid she has
to sacrifice her ability to speak the
old-fashioned way by letting the sea
which cut out her tongue and once on
land despite living in the princes
palace where she silently perpetually
pines for him the heroine never even
comes close to getting her man
instead he friends owns her and marries
somebody else that leaves her with two
terrible choices she can either stop the
prince to death on his wedding night or
she can kill herself needless to say she
takes the noble option and throws
herself into the sea at which point it
turns out that her act of sacrifice has
earned her a place in heaven but only
after she's forced to spend 300 years in
purgatory as an invisible wind spirit
even Ursula thinks that's going a bit
too far Pocahontas much as we love the
Disney take on this old-school American
legend the true story of Pocahontas is
mostly just kind of sad for one thing
she was just 11 years old when she saved
Captain John Smith's life by convincing
her father not to execute him the two of
them never had a romance instead the
teenaged Pocahontas married a fellow
Powhatan but was taken captive in 1613
by the English although her father tried
to negotiate and bring her back
Pocahontas quickly converted to
Christianity changed her name to Rebecca
and married a tobacco farmer named John
Rolfe she ultimately followed Rolfe to
England and died there the following
year at age 20 never having seen her
father or family again Beauty and the
Beast
lovely bookish Belle is one of the most
memorable heroines in Disney history but
in John Murray LeBrons Daboo man's
Beauty and the Beast the original story
on which the movie was based the
circumstances that led to her coming to
stay with the transfigured prince are a
lot more questionable in the original
Beauty and the Beast beauty's father
gets on the Beast bad sight and the
Beast decides that either dear old dad
or one of his daughters must die as a
punishment
the father offers himself but Belle
volunteers instead but beasts can't
bring himself to kill her on account of
the butterflies in his stomach he
proposes marriage to her every day for
three months before letting her go back
to her dad's house for a visit
Beauty returns to the castle to find the
beasts near death not at the hands of
God
stun who doesn't even exist in this
version but the Beast has been
intentionally starving himself as a
twisted form of emotional manipulation
it works and Beauty agrees to marry him
to stop him from killing himself now if
that isn't true love I don't know what
is thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]